[Music]
hi my name is laura and i'm a private
chef and today katie has challenged me
to create a dessert based off of one of
her favorite celebrity looks i don't
know who katie chose but it's right here
behind me so let's find out
it's silly eilish
yeah i love her style i feel like it's
kind of like mine but it's weird because
i'm older
and she's cooler so it's not fair what
really intrigues me about this look is
the amount of lime green the glitter and
how spooky and black it is oh the rules
so the rules are one must be a cake two
must include a chocolate technique and
three must incorporate the grammys the
dessert that i'm gonna have to make
today is gonna have to be glam and
glitter and just it has to be dark and
sexy this is my first challenge at tasty
i'm a little nervous let's do this
the first thing we're going to do is
bake the cake it's hot coffee and cocoa
powder one is black cocoa that you would
use for oreos we're going to try to make
this cake nice and dark coffee just
enhances chocolate flavor and it just
creates the deepness that you don't get
when you just use water we've got our
flour salt baking soda and baking powder
and then we're just gonna use a whisk to
whisk it all together to get it all
incorporated we're gonna add our eggs to
the sugar and whip them for about three
minutes
we're looking for a light yellow
so we're gonna start with
a third of our dries
slap it
to make a cake spooky i think we're
gonna try to get it nice and dark and
mysterious i've just always liked like
horror movies anything like anything
goosebumps definitely a hot topic goth
in middle school to high school so what
i've learned in cake making is you
always want to finish when you're
alternating wets and dries you always
want to finish with the dry you want to
finish
your cake batters by hand this is just
what i was taught you want to let the
machine help you but the machine
shouldn't finish the cake batter so
it'll be tough human touch now we have
our finished plain batter we're going to
divide it into two bowls and get the two
colors working but to give it a little
bit more of the billy eilish buy we're
going to use some really dark black food
coloring
and get that in there we're gonna use
pandan extract pandan is like the asian
vanilla pandan is a green leaf that's
extracted and has very vanilla and sweet
notes and a very vibrant green color
this is feeling very billy so here's our
dark batter and then we're gonna do same
amount of green and we're just gonna
keep alternating that until all of the
batter is done so then we're just gonna
take an offset spatula
and gently
run it through the batter just trying to
create some more interesting
contrast between the two batters it
looks exactly how i want it to so i'm
pretty pleased all right i'm gonna go
bake this for 25 minutes and i'll be
right back
so next we're going to make a cookies
and cream mousse first thing we're going
to do is take hot cream and pour it over
the chocolate and let that hang out
while we whip our cream and then just
whip it until you're at soft peak so now
i'm just going to take the same beaters
and i'm just going to mix the warm
chocolate and cream
just to get them nice and incorporated
it's called a sacrifice and i think that
kind of ties into how spooky this cake
is gonna be but we gotta sacrifice some
of our cold cream
to temper our warm chocolate ganache and
it's just gonna get it on a closer
temperature so that it doesn't just
seize up when you pour hot into cold and
then we're just gonna do a traditional
folding technique from top to bottom
this is now a good time to add our oreo
crumbs billy has said that she wears
baggy clothes to kind of keep her body
hidden away from judgment and critique
so i think we just want to hide an
element to this cake so that when we cut
in we see inside and it's something
interesting so i'm using this cool
silicone mold that's really popular on
like instagram videos but it's got these
weird bubbly spheres and it ties into
that whole gooey oozy slimy look we just
want it to be nice and filled up
so just doing a little cap from the
bottom the tappa tap was a professional
technique and now we're going to take
this to the freezer
[Music]
now we're going to make the mirror glaze
that's going to go on top of the mousse
and so we have gelatin and we're going
to quickly add water and mix it really
fast into a paste we're going to set
this aside while we heat up our sugar
water and condensed milk and i think it
is the most impressive looking thing
that i think we're going to do for this
cake once this gets to a boil we're
gonna add our gelatin and our vanilla
extract mirror glazes are like the resin
pores of the if you high section on
instagram and now we're just gonna pour
it over carefully
and then just let this sit for a few
moments and then we're going to blend it
all together
all right now we're ready for color and
we're going to
use the same pandan extract again about
a tablespoon
time to buzz
this is done and then we're just gonna
strain it
into a bowl i'm gonna repeat this method
again using dark chocolate and cocoa
powder and then we're gonna get our
black glaze
so i really love billy's nails
especially in this look i feel like her
long glamorous nails are something that
she's known for so i really want to
incorporate that into the cake and i've
got to do a chocolate technique anyway
so let's do it with this so we've got
some melted dark chocolate and i've got
this cold sheet tray
and then we're just gonna pour it
i'm gonna try to spread it out as thin
as possible i'm gonna pop this in the
freezer so that it sets up for the next
layer so next i'm going to try to
replicate that gucci pattern with some
white chocolate that we're going to pipe
and then cover in green glitter so i'm
just going to do
one direction
and i want to move really fast because
this chocolate will set
and i think before then i'm gonna just
try to get this layer on oh we're
getting messy make sure it's working ooh
it's working i am feeling the pressure
also just because i can see the
chocolate setting so i'm like oh and it
gets the glitter on i think i'm just
going to do a couple dots because i want
to it's definitely
always hard to know when to stop
especially when it's fun all right so
now i'm going to lift this up and get
all that extra glitter out of the way
now that this is done let's just break
it up into shards
i definitely find a lot of fun in the
like physical stuff i'm not sure how
i'll use it yet but i like all the
points and i feel like it's like jagged
and edgy kind of how billy is okay so
we're going to move on to our gold
element next
so in order to incorporate the rule that
i have to involve the grammys i'm going
to do chocolate covered strawberries but
we're going to cover them in gold
billy's got five grammys so i wanna make
five gold strawberries to show that on
the cake so i've already taken some
strawberries that i've cut and i'm just
gonna stick it in the chocolate i wanna
cover it completely and then we're gonna
take one
fancy big piece of gold leaf nailed it
it's like putting a blanket of gold on
the little strawberry
this is how they apply gold leaf to old
paintings and old instruments
all right these look good let's move on
to our next step
we're gonna move on to coloring our
buttercream and this is just a plain
vanilla buttercream that we're gonna
color green with more of the pandan
extract you're gonna start noticing it
in a bunch of other things i can't wait
to see pandan on the tick tock cooking
videos having billy behind me is really
uh it's like having a spooky guardian in
the sky and i think she's really helping
the vibe all right well i think we got
it to match the spatula pretty well so
now we're gonna cut the cakes to size
we've made this little template that's
about the size of the molds oh look at
we got some green here very cool
billy if you're watching this right now
i hope you like what i'm making and i
hope that you can come over and eat it
one day and we could be friends so we're
gonna use this template and put it here
tiny bit of icing so it doesn't slide
around and
flip
whoa see how black that is crazy and
we're gonna build a little two layer
cake with this frosting in between i
think we really got the color of her
hair in this cake somewhere so now this
is done and our next step is to assemble
the cake and do the mirror glaze which
is kind of the like i'm holding my
breath and i'm kind of running out of
air because i'm a little nervous that
i'm going to mess this up but we're
going to do it mirror glaze
we've done all of our components and now
it's time for the mirror glaze and we
only get one shot i don't have an extra
one i want billy to tell me that i could
do whatever i want and she'd love it
all right so let's do this and start
from the middle and i'm not going to
stop until i feel comfortable that every
last inch
was covered
and then we're just gonna do our green
glaze
ooh look we're getting the nice strips
that we want all right so i'm happy with
this we're going to move on to hopefully
the easier one work on making sure that
these sides are completely covered so
let's just add a little bit of extra
green
ooh this is definitely a goosebumps
vibe right here wow i love that so now
i'm gonna quickly use two spatulas to
get this layer on top and then we're
gonna
[Music]
that's like
stuck
[Music]
so now we're just gonna use our
chocolate
and kind of build up our accents this is
like a spooky gingerbread house i'm
gonna move around to placing the gold
strawberries so i'm kind of trying to
emulate how she has all of the grammys
together and she's actually got one
that's like on its own so let's do that
here
okay we're done i'm so excited to be
done that was really stressful and i'm
so glad we made it i love the cake and i
can't wait to see what katie thinks of
this billy eilish cake
[Music]
it's so good it really like it's it's
screaming billy to me like i
and the gold leaf on are these
strawberries i love this like ooey gooey
like this needs to be in one of her
music videos it's creepy but it's glam
i cannot wait to see the inside of it so
laura i'm gonna let you come in and cut
it because i don't dare good job laura
thank you
it's time to cut the cake
she sliced this pretty are we ready for
the big reveal
oh wow
it at a point felt like i wasn't doing
enough for this cake to like do justice
for how big her personality is but
i think looking at this i'm pretty
excited about the cake that we made
together
all right let's take a bite
get every layer
it's really good
gold doesn't give a flavor but it gives
a flavor
[Laughter]
i'm so glad katie challenged me to do
this cake if you guys are interested in
seeing any other celebrity looks turned
into food please let us know in the
comments down below thanks so much for
watching bye
this bad guy is everything i wanted and
definitely something i would eat when
the party's over
[Music]
you